[Music]
rochelle is with us rochelle's in los
angeles hi rochelle how are you
hi how are you i'm doing great dave
thank you so very much for taking my
call sure what's up
okay so i have a company lease vehicle i
know don't kill me i i know i know no
and i wanted to find out what are your
thoughts on even though it the company
pays for the lease i am currently on my
way to
um i'm in step number
three for right now of my baby step but
my question is do i pay off the lease
or do i sell it now that the that the
market is so high
meaning like one of us is confused
okay me or you won me or you won okay
there is no such thing
as a company lease
either the company owns the car and
they're furnishing you the car
or you went and leased a car
and you have a car allowance
correct number two i use the vehicles
underneath my name and the company gives
me um 500 a month which by the way they
would give you if the car was paid for
oh okay they give you the 500 either way
so you don't have a company lease
there's no such thing okay
you have at least car you have a leased
car and your company gives you money as
a car allowance for the use of your
personal vehicle
correct and if you get fired tomorrow
you've got to pay that lease out yep
correct so this is a debt you have and
um
you need to get the either the car paid
off or get it sold one of the two
as soon as you can as soon as you can i
mean can can you just pay the lease off
i mean if you've have you called and
asked for the early buyout figure
um i did i haven't called yet but i did
i just looked on the statement and it's
um 28 thousand dollars
20 000 and change yeah no maybe uh let's
let's go back a minute because there's
two things show up on these statements
there's is that the total of all
remaining payments
um the are you talking about like the
reviews the 28 000. now the 28 000 would
be the residual plus all remaining
payments that's a total that's a top
figure a total of payments that is not
the early buyout the early buyout is
what they will let you pay it off for
today which does not include
what we call interest but they call cost
of capital
okay i would have to call to get that
exact number but i believe um it's
closer to like thirty two thousand and
thirty three thousand no it would be
less than twenty eight thousand
not including the final payment and the
residual amount
to buy out the vehicle
okay you're misunderstanding
okay i'm sorry okay i'm nervous sorry
that's okay let's walk through it right
quick because i want to make because
it's good for everybody to understand
what could be showing on your statement
is one of two different numbers the 28
000 is one of these two numbers okay
it could be the residual value is what
you can buy the car for at the end of
the lease
okay plus
all of your payments up until the end of
the lease how long until the end of the
lease
okay i have exactly 12 months left okay
so 12 times your payment plus the
residual
does that equal 28 000
no sir it's actually more okay then the
28 000 is probably your early buyout
because that's the total obligation you
have that the more number
12 payments plus the residual value the
early buyout is as if you paid off your
car 12 months early
and it saves you 12 months of interest
on twenty thirty thousand bucks so it's
probably three thousand dollars less
than the total of payments and something
i don't ever know which is showing up on
these statements unless they are very
clear with it so
if you can sell the car for more than 28
000 you probably should and then let's
figure out a way to get you a car bought
that your your company approves of so
you continue to get the um
car allowance and if you take out a
little bit of debt on that that's less
than you have now that's a good thing